this is astounding and it doesn't seem
like many people are talking about this
at all there are sparks of artificial
general intelligence with early
experiments of gpt4 this comes from
Microsoft research and in this paper
they demonstrate that beyond the Mastery
of language gpt4 can solve and model
tasks regarding mathematics Vision
medicine law psychology without needing
special prompting there are putnam-like
problems in mathematics that can be done
by this AI this is a number theoretic
problem and it's not simple to solve GPT
does it extremely well it even does
integrals which is extremely impressive
how does this come from a large language
model I'm interested in the implications
of this for physics but what does this
mean for Humanity in its most
deleterious sense think about what this
means AGI is the Holy Grail of
artificial intelligence research and it
already seems like gpt4 has the ink
Links of that what will gpt5 be like
Wolfram talks about this in an episode
premiering now on physics and AI Link in
the description